With studios lining up to adapt every bankable
superhero or comic book icon to the big screen,
you might think that fans would be happy with
what they have coming. But every comic fan
has their favorites, and sometimes, it's the
most unlikely superheroes that could end up
being the biggest box office surprises. Here
are Screen Rant's 10 Superhero Movies We Would
Love To See.
X-Force
Anyone who's read an X-Force story knows why
the strike team is perfect for Fox's shared
universe. Pairing deadly heroes like Deadpool
with Psylocke and Archangel - both joining
the movie universe in X-Men Apocalypse - would
guarantee action, as the covert, unsanctioned
side of the X-Men seek out mutant threats,
and end them before they make trouble. With
the team leader, Cable getting a role in the
Deadpool sequel - and a spot for Wolverine,
should Hugh Jackman want to try an R-Rated
ensemble - Fox would be crazy not to make
this sooner than later.
Secret Six
They may seem like another Suicide Squad,
but the Secret Six - a team of villains working
together on a massive score - are the ones
being chased, not the other way around. When
Deadshot, Catman, Bane, and more team up to
transport a prisoner across the country, a
bounty is put on their heads, drawing every
gangster, goon and killer out after them.
If DC's Suicide Squad ends up a hit, then
a spinoff like Secret Six could give fans
an even stranger, more supernatural dose - on
a much smaller budget, and with characters
less tied to other franchises. That's assuming
the studio will have room alongside their
big screen Justice League.
Ms. Marvel
Since kids everywhere are getting more and
more obsessed with Marvel's Avengers, it seems
crazy to NOT make a movie based on the new
Ms. Marvel, Kamala Khan - a teenage girl who
gets incredible superpowers, and decides to
follow in the footsteps of her favorite hero:
Captain Marvel. The comic was a critical hit,
starring a Pakistani-American heroine, and
dealing with a coming-of-age tale while also
telling a superhero origin. Since Captain
Marvel is coming to the big screen, with the
Inhumans like Kamala not far behind, focusing
a movie on her personal story could be a nice
counterpoint to the massive Avengers event
movies.
The Metal Men
Doctor Will Magnus didn't know what he was
creating when he added microcomputers to liquid
metal, but what he ended up with was The Metal
Men: metallic robots with strengths and personalities
all based on the metal they're made of. Before
long, Gold, Platinum, Mercury, Iron, Tin and
Lead were using their shapeshifting powers
to take down enemies born right out of science
fiction. The humor of a movie based on the
comic is hard to miss, but the action could
be just as good. Especially once they stop
shapeshifting in battle and combine to form
Alloy, a massive robot warrior with ALL of
their powers. Just picture the toy sales!
Spawn
The demonic hero created by Todd McFarlane
got his big screen debut in 1997, before comic
book movies were mainstream hits, but still
managed to keep fans happy. The cartoon series
kept the love going, and the creator hasn't
given up on a sequel - or remake - just yet.
In recent years, McFarlane has claimed to
have a script all but finished, with Oscar
winner Jamie Foxx on board to play the marine-turned-Hellspawn
terrorizing the criminals of his city. It's
still one of the darkest comic book movies
to ever get made, and got enough right to
earn a second look. So if studios are looking
for an R-Rated anti-hero, having a movie star
already on board is half the battle.
Moon Knight
He might seem like a Batman rip-off, but Marvel’s
Moon Knight is even weirder. When a former
Marine and mercenary winds up surrounded by
ancient Egyptian artifacts, dying at the feet
of a statue of Khonshu, the Egyptian Moon
God, Marc Spector agrees to be resurrected
as the god's new host. It's a gift and a curse,
since the revival fractures Marc's mind, changing
his personality with the phases of the moon.
The only thing scarier than a super-strong,
gadget-wielding mystical vigilante? One who
doesn't try to avoid painful punches and kicks,
seeing them as punishment for the life he
used to live. Talk about issues.
Lobo
DC may not have a match for Deadpool, but
Lobo comes pretty close. The immortal, self-healing,
murder-loving intergalactic bounty hunter
was created as a parody of the ultra-violent
Marvel heroes Wolverine and Punisher, but
ended up becoming a fan-favorite anyway. In
the year since he was introduced, Lobo has
weaved his way through every cosmic DC story,
meaning a Lobo movie could take place virtuallyanywhere.
Still need another reason? His immortality
isn't just genetics: when Lobo died and went
to Hell, they threw him out, up to Heaven.
The angels couldn't handle him either, permanently
banning him from the afterlife. Tell us that
isn't a comic book movie waiting to be told.
Captain Comet
If there's one genre of film that's enjoying
as much of a boost as comic books, it's science
fiction - and the more attitude and personality,
the better. Casual fans might think that the
deep space side of DC's movie universe is
just for the Green Lanterns and New Gods,
but there are some seedier locations, too.
Take Hardcore Station, the stomping grounds
of the galaxy's surliest citizens. The setting
was the real star of DC's "Mystery in Space"
mini-series, following the exploits of the
telekinetic, telephathic, teleporting superhero
known as Captain Comet. A mutant even older
than Marvel's X-Men, and a mix of the heroes
of Guardians of the Galaxy, Firefly, and Star
Wars, he's the perfect hero to show DC's cosmic
world has a sense of humor, too.
Beta Ray Bill
Just because a movie seems like a long shot,
that doesn't mean we want it any less. The
version of Thor in the MCU truly has the strength
of a god, but the comic books had him meet
his match in an alien calling itself 'Beta
Ray Bill,' one of the last survivors of the
Korbinite race. The fact that he could actually
beat the thunder god and take his hammer shows
he has star potential, but is just as noble
as any Asgardian - the reason Odin had a hammer
made for him from the same dying star. The
horse-faced warrior was an instant favorite
of Marvel readers, and with the stakes being
raised higher than ever in Thor 3, having
a beloved replacement ready to take over for
Thor wouldn't hurt.
The Runaways
It's one thing to find out you're the child
of a superhero, but what if you discovered
your parents were as super-villainous as they
come? That's what happened to Marvel's Runaways,
who reacted by doing what any hero would:
stealing their parents' gadgets and weapons,
and training to right their wrongs, becoming
the super-protectors of the city they tried
to destroy. It's a story no movie has come
close to touching, which is why the teen team-up
was originally in the works at Marvel. But
it was shelved to make room for The Avengers'
shared universe. That doesn't mean the movie's
been canceled, but Marvel shouldn't miss out
on this idea which, in the right hands, could
really be something special for the MCU.
Those are just a handful of comic book heroes
and heroines we would love to see on the big
screen, but what are your own picks? Do you
think the big studios are missing out on some
of their best properties? Let us know what
you think in the comments, and remember to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one!